so this is Sigma five five two right yep
I was looking for a gun that was good
like in close quarters but had a little
bit of range sure the advantage for the
sig five five two is because of the
folding stock you have a lot shorter
profile for a weapon it's a great
advantage simply because when you do
fold it allows you to get around corners
much quicker you can make a much smaller
profile so I won't show a difference
does having a longer barrel make like
nine day how much would like two inches
on barrel like May compared you're
talking about maybe 50 yards or you know
25 50 yards because the farther away you
get obviously because it's a round ball
it's not a bullet there's no rifling so
you know you don't have like a spinning
football that's going far it's a BB
that's just back spinning can tell you a
little bit about like the internals in
this gun I mean essentially an airsoft
gun is just like a nerf gun it uses
compressed air to fire a BB but the way
it generates that compressed air is with
a piston and a cylinder now the only way
that you're going to be able to actuate
a piston and cylinder is by cocking a
spring so you've got some sort of
tension being released to to give you
air pressure so the way does that is a
battery operates a motor which is down
here in the motor grip the motor spins a
pinion gear and then you've got a sector
and spur gear the sector's up here in
the spur gear just translates one gear
to another so it's all about ratios you
know the the speed the number of rounds
are going to be shooting per minute is
all you know based off of the gear ratio
all right so there's a million types of
scopes and optics you can put on the
rifle yes okay so what is like really
the main like difference between say
like something like one of these EOTech
ones or this for example sure
and the advantage for going with like a
bravo 5 v 2 is because the red dot is
able to move inside no matter what angle
you're looking through it you're still
going to get where it's going to fire
downrange so let's say you're not 100%
behind the weapon even if you're off to
an angle you're able to see what you're
saying
anybody that's played paintball or
airsoft indoors for any period of time
knows that you're dealing with fogging
heat around your face like for minutes
and minutes on end and that gets really
frustrating and difficult to play
not to mention like you have to like
wipe your goggles like while you're
playing so going to a mess mat mesh mask
you eliminate the heat around your face
you're able to breathe a lot easier your
breathing's not restricted and you're
not dealing with anywhere near the the
fogging issues that you would mask with
lenses but those kind of fill the gap
between doing a half faced mesh mask and
a set of goggles and a full mask which
doesn't have any mesh all right guys
yeah we're all kitted out thanks to
these guys and all those guys behind the
camera mm-hmm did an awesome job so Sam
a little bit about what you got why do
you want to go with this nice fine piece
of weaponry here but I was noticing a
lot with these rifles is that you know
that they're not so great for doing
close quarters but this one balances it
perfectly and that plus an awesome
element scope here combining a red dot
and a laser it's perfect for me and I'm
with the Sig 5 5 - um main idea is that
you can you know pull the stock and I
can take out the sounds or also have a
really small gun for doing nice indoor
close quarters got a sweet flashlight
that can strobe and like blind people I
got exterior battery pack which makes it
really easy to put batteries in and out
got a sweet sight with a laser
because lasers are cool yeah the
difference between the the sync 5 5 -
that you've chosen and the hk416 that
he's using is that his his batteries
aren't held in a PQ box like yours his
are instead held in the crane stock in
the back they're both easily removable
they're both easy to get to the
batteries it's just two different ways
of outfitting the guns Nico why did you
pick that mask
I picked this mask because it looks cool
it's actually it's specially well made
and you guys are the only guys who had
these kind of masks right yeah that's
true yeah you're out of them what do you
do Oh teddy is my sidearm Oh Oh what do
you get
I got a mark 4 1911 and you were looking
for something more calm yeah the USP
compact I I mean not gonna lie I think
is one of the best-looking guns out
there in tactical oil patches I'm I got
a facebook like and my American flag and
then I got a fun meter the nice fun
meters all the way up on my side so
maximum fun meter hi guys well thanks so
much no problem yeah absolutely guys I
don't see any ice time you'll see it'll
be an
actually to see you guys in some airsoft
games at our place yeah cool dudes